what we see here is known as a trophic
pyramid and the word profic in a biology
context is referring to food
relationships so one way to think about
this it tells us who is eating whom and
who is producing energy and then who is
able to leverage that energy so at the
base of a trophic pyramid you have your
primary producers
primary
producers
these are often known as autotrophs
because they're able to take energy from
the sun
so sun's
energy
and nutrients that are available to them
and
store some of that energy as biomass and
biomass is just a fancy word for the
actual substance of the organism that is
inherently storing energy when someone
tells you that that piece of food has a
certain number of calories that's
because there's energy stored in it
calories are a unit of energy
and so let's just say if you were to
take a square meter if you were to
average on a per square meter basis
these primary producers in this
environment let's say they're able to
store
20 000
kilocalories
per square meter per year
what's interesting about a trophic
pyramid it helps describe well okay that
energy stored at biomass what happens
then
well then you could go to the next level
and you could view these as your primary
or first level consumers
so
first level
i could call them level one or primary
consumers
these are the organisms that would eat
the primary producers but not all of
that energy gets restored as biomass in
these organisms in fact there is a lot
of loss on average when we look at
ecosystems it tends to be only about 10
percent makes it from one level of our
trophic pyramid to the next so at this
level on a per on average per square
meter instead of 20 000 kilocalories
being stored as biomass per year you'd
only have 10 percent of that so it might
only be 2 000
2 000 kilocalories per square meter per
year so notice you have that drop off
and then you go to the next level after
that you could view these as the
secondary consumers these are the folks
who might eat the primary consumers the
first level consumers you get another 10
drop off so you or i should say 90 drop
off only 10 percent gets transferred so
about 200
200 kilocalories per square meter per
year and it keeps happening the folks
who eat those folks well then you've
dropped off at this level right over
here you could call these the third
level consumers or sometimes viewed as
tertiary consumers this would be
this would be
about
kilocalories
per square meter per year and this
doesn't mean that every square meter
will have exactly 20 kilocalories of
biomass of let's say in this example
snake it just means that if you look at
the biomass of snakes and you were to
average them across this ecosystem the
surface area that you might average
about 20 kilocalories per square meter
per year and then you get to the top of
this pyramid and this you could use your
level four consumer you could view this
as since they're at the top of the
pyramid this is sometimes known as the
apex predator but every stage here you
only are able to transfer ten percent of
the biomass so here you have two
kilocalories per square meter per year
and what's useful about this it helps us
understand what an ecosystem can support
it can support a lot of biomass of our
primary producers but it can support
very little biomass of our apex
predators and that's why
if you were to go into the forest you
would see very few apex predators if you
were to look at the apex predators and
you were to think about their biomass in
terms of kilocalories and spread it over
their region where they have to find
food it would be much lower than the
average biomass per square meter of say
the grass and the trees
now an interesting thing is well where
is where is a lot of that energy getting
lost to well a lot of cases these
organisms are moving around they have to
do things they have processes in their
own body and those things all generate
heat so even plants
even plants generate heat so all of
these characters are
there's some energy that's being
released as heat
also when these when these players die
they're decomposed by other organisms so
all this biomass it's either just going
to die or it's going to get eaten but
even when it gets eaten all of the
energy doesn't get transferred some of
it stays in the undigested material
which we refer to as poop and so those
dead bodies that those that dead biomass
or this poop that still contains energy
is going to be fed on by what we call
decomposers
decomposers and they really break things
down into nutrients which then can be
consumed by the primary producers as
they utilize the sun's energy and keep
the cycle going after that
now one interesting thing to think about
is what if there are changes to the
ecosystem what if for example of all a
nearby volcano erupts and that volcano
let me draw that it's a fun thing to
draw that volcano erupts and ash goes
into the sky and all year it's just it's
just really gray what would you think
would happen
well
the sun's energy that's able to hit the
surface of the earth in this area would
go down by a good bit and so if that
went down by a good bit then the primary
producers might not be able to store
twenty thousand kilocalories per square
meter per year it might go down to two
thousand kilocalories per square meter
per year and in which case you dropped a
zero off of all of these so instead of
twenty thousand it might go to two
thousand instead of two thousand this
would be 200 instead of 200 this would
be 20 instead of 20 this would be 2
instead of 2 this would 0.2
and so something like the loss of light
energy even though this apex predator
doesn't directly photosynthesize a lot
fewer of them are going to be able to be
supported in that ecosystem if you have
a lot less energy stored at biomass at
the primary production level because
there's just less of sun's energy to be
able to be stored as biomass there could
be other things that can happen in the
ecosystem let's say that some pesticides
get introduced and some of these level 1
consumers start dying out well then you
might have less of the transfer of
biomass from the primary producer level
to the primary consumer level which once
again might affect these other levels of
the trophic pyramid so this is an
interesting thing to think about
ecosystems are these really complex
intertwined things and one impact at one
area what could have far reaching
consequences throughout the entire
ecosystem
it's also interesting to think of
ecosystems as energy transfer energy is
coming from the sun and it's being
cycled through this ecosystem through
this pyramid some of it gets stored as
biomass and gets transferred to other
forms of biomass but a lot of it gets
lost as heat as these organisms cells go
through different processes the
organisms are running around living
their life doing whatever